l'appel de l'association des maires de
France a été relayée un peu partout sur
le territoire rassemblement devant les
mairies contre les émeutes urbaines et
en soutien aux maires pris pour cible
lors des nuits de violence sur place et
lui et simples citoyen ils étaient
environ 150 atouts même nombre à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps Faustine
les maires de France appellent donc
Davy Irlande républicain un
rassemblement qui débute par un discours
des élus à Tours une centaine de
personnes ont répondu à l'appel de
l'association des maires de France même
chose à Saint-Pierre-des-Corps le maire
de cette commune ainsi que celui de la
riche ont chacun été pris pour cible
lors des émeutes alors pour les
habitants présents se réunir ce midi
était une évidence pour ce film
je dors pas que ça soit là ou l'autre
mère je ne vois pas pour quelle raison
qu'on ne viendrait pas c'est une chose
qu'il faut qu'il faut se déplacer
maintenant
on est obligé de soutenir il y a une
solidarité pour
pour la ville et la situation la justice
ça doit se faire au tribunal le temps de
l'enquête est importante et on fait pas
la justice en brûlant des voitures la
semaine dernière dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi Emmanuel François le maire de
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps a vu sa voiture
incendiée sous ses yeux la mairie la
bibliothèque ainsi que d'autres lieux de
la commune ont également été vandalisés
alors se rassemblement les mœurs
particulièrement
c'est hallucinant le voir autant de
monde et vraiment des messages de
fraternité et ça ça fait plaisir la
fraternité aussi parce que c'est le
ciment de la solidarité Emmanuel
François sera demain par le Président de
la République